The public didn't buy the Biden administration and
the Federal Reserve's claims that inflation was
likely transitory. Concern about increasing prices
has been percolating in the polls for months
and it is having a powerful effect on the
president's ratings. In the Harvard/Harrispoll
from November 2021, Biden's approval rating
on handling the economy dropped 20 points since
his inauguration, from 61 to 41%. Less than half,
45%, expressed confidence in the administration,
and separately in the Fed, to keep inflation atbay.
In the mid-November Wall Street Journal poll,
registered voters gave Republicans in Congress
an 18-point lead over the Democrats on being
better able to get inflation under control. As for
the effect inflation is having on Americans,
19% in the December Monmouth University poll
said that they cut back a lot, and 21% a little,
on holiday gifts because of high prices. 34% have
experienced more shipping delays than in the past,
and 46% of experienced items being out of stock.
Did you have trouble buying a holiday gift? Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.